dan schneider may be ready for his
hollywood comeback but is the public
ready to accept him stay tuned for all
the controversial details for years
prolific producer dan schneider occupied
a prominent place in the world of
children's television throughout the
late 90s and odds schneider and his
schneider's bakery banner oversaw many
hit shows on nickelodeon including all
that keenan and kell drake and josh and
icarly at the height of his fame
schneider was compared to fellow tv
titan norman lear by the new york times
a comparison that should indicate just
how respected he was at one point in
time then in march 2018 schneider's time
at nickelodeon suddenly ended due to
allegations of verbal abuse and
questionable treatment to the young
stars who appeared on his shows
investigations were reportedly conducted
by viacom cbs and the two parties
eventually parted ways nickelodeon and
schneider issued a joint statement to
addressing his departure following many
conversations together about next
directions and future opportunities
nickelodeon and our longtime creative
partner dan schneider schneider's bakery
have agreed to not extend the current
deal since several schneider's bakery
projects are wrapping up both sides
agreed that this is a natural time for
nickelodeon and schneider's bakery to
pursue other opportunities and projects
in the immediate wake of schneider's
exit he remained out of the public eye
and did not comment on the events of
2018 three years later the icarly
producer was back on the record
addressing these sensitive topics in a
june 2021 interview with the new york
times schneider opened up about his
departure from nickelodeon and commented
on the allegations against him that
accompanied news of his exit
at the time of schneider's leave from
nickelodeon reports had been swirling a
possible controversial behavior on set
the march 2018 deadline report on the
producer split with a kid-friendly tv
network included notes about allegations
of snyder's temper disrupting work
production delays ballooning budgets and
complaints of abusive behavior against
him filed by his staff more concerning
was the section of deadlines report that
contained the following for years
schneider had been under a cloud of
suspicion over the treatment of some
younger stars of his shows among the
things that have raised eyebrows are his
tweeted photos of the toes of his young
female stars
it's video
i got you
a viacom cbs investigation found that
schneider was allegedly yelling and
throwing tantrums as well as sending
angry emails and texts to child actors
outside of working hours according to a
july 2021 deadline report he also
allegedly asked for shoulder and neck
massages addressing the accusations the
producer told the new york times i never
interacted with actors in any way
texting or otherwise that should make
anyone uncomfortable he called the
controversy over the feet pictures
ridiculous saying i couldn't and i
wouldn't have the long-term friendships
and continued loyalty from so many
reputable people if i'd mistreated my
actors of any age especially minors
schneider claimed that if anyone he
worked with over the years saw him as
difficult it was because of the high
standards he held for his work the
longtime producer admitted however that
he may have been a little harsh at times
he said over the years i've grown and
matured as a producer and leader i'm
sure i'm better and more gentle at
communicating today the new york times
spoke to people from schneider's past in
addition to the producer for the june
2021 interview arthur gradstein a writer
and producer who worked with schneider
on four different shows recalled the
stresses of their partnership bradstein
told the publication schneider could be
generous and validating and it was
exciting to be around his talent and
passion for creating entertainment but
he was also unreasonably demanding
controlling belittling and vindictive
with a willful disregard for boundaries
or workplace appropriateness grandstein
is one of many people who have publicly
engaged with schneider and the
allegations he faces several unnamed
sources also spoke to the new york times
and validated previous reports of
schneider's allegedly abusive ways
previously fans compiled instances where
feet were featured on a schneider
produced show for bizarre reasons in an
effort to highlight a possible
connection to schneider and allegations
against him of inappropriate behavior
involving child actors i'm carly i'm sam
and we like to draw families on our toes
observe
while schneider did not specifically
mention the allegations in the new york
times 2021 interview he did note that
his 2018 departure from nickelodeon was
due to things he had long ignored over
the years he explained i took a break to
take care of a lot of stuff that i'd let
go by the wayside for decades three
years after his departure from
nickelodeon schneider told the new york
times he was ready to return to work he
explained i don't want to be an old man
someday and look it up and see some
episode of one of the shows i did and go
ugh and be disappointed in myself
whatever i do next i wanted to outdo
what i've done in the past while details
are unclear schneider claimed to have a
comeback pilot in the works which he
described to the new york times as
ambitious and very different the show
will reportedly be geared more toward an
adult audience overall schneider
reportedly holds no grudges against
nickelodeon over his exit the new york
times story found no evidence of sexual
misconduct by schneider nor did the
viacom cbs investigation which occurred
at the height of the me 2 movement
schneider said he ultimately wishes the
channel the best in its future endeavors
including the icarly reboot currently
airing on paramount plus
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you